well the last video i
made was uh ikikai vs iwama
and uh each time
the two names are mentioned it brings an
array of
good and bad comments on facebook and on
youtube
i tried to keep it balanced but
obviously people are
not quite seeing it in the same light as
i'm seeing it
i think you should be as truthful as you
can without
trying to hurt people so that's not my
intention
never is but um
i keep hearing the words aikido
needs to evolve everything evolves
and i have a
simple word it's called
why such a sense he mentioned to me once
and i've said this before
why would anybody want to change those
senses aikido
before they become as good as osensei
you might think they're just simple
words but when he
said it he wasn't on the mat
he was in his key no sorry he wasn't on
the mat in his key
he was just in his everyday work clothes
his little braces and his
black trousers he had a t-shirt on
i don't know if it was white or
semi-white due to him working in the
garden most days
but you know i i looked his face the
same as if
you know you're looking at my face now i
looked at his face and um
you could see that he was so daydreaming
questioning like
like i'm looking up now he was
questioning
the words he was telling me
and he's and i said i don't understand
it sensei
i can't give you an answer
so why don't we think about what he said
okay he's not oh scentsy he's just
another human being like me and you
but why would you want to change those
senses aikido before you become as good
as i sense
yourself please consider that
before you say aikido must evolve
of course it evolves we become
the human race becomes modified it
changes
we're not the people that they were 100
years ago
we live longer now we ask more questions
we're more inquisitive
and the worst western world perhaps far
more than the
eastern world
i have to check myself out because
what i'm going to say in this film is
about i key down my thoughts
on how i see it evolving and
changing from the aikido that i learned
and the one i learned to believe was
aikido because if a master like
cytoscencia or one of your masters
old japanese standing master
who was taught by osensei not someone
who just has a theory that
hasn't gone much further than the next
street from their dojo
in life
but someone who's lived there been there
done it
and trained with their scentsy they
should have a pretty good opinion
of how aikido should be performed now
and
in the future it's my opinion
but it also bothers me that as i get
older
i don't want to become just a grumpy old
man
because that's what appears to happen to
most people as they get older
they become grumpy because the world's
not going
according to how they think it should
i'm happy for it to evolve i'm happy for
changes to be made opinions variations
and lots of things but the one thing i'd
like to talk about today
is aikido going off in a tangent
when i see every day
my facebook i've got four and a half
thousand
friends and i would think at least
four thousand five hundred and fifty of
them
are aikidoka around the world
then i go on to see what people are
posting and their
aikido demonstrations or training in
their club
having a lot of fun when i watch
even the top japanese teachers doing
demonstrations
how much zanzin have they got some of
them have got
really good sanction
i was watching a film a few days ago
of the top french master 8th dan
christian tisiere i like his ikida a lot
no it's not my guido but it's a
very good form of aikido in my opinion
i like watched him because to me he's
keeping the martial attitude but more
importantly
when he is with his uk's
or uk you can see that he's
also looking all around him
he's watching he's he's not just
with the uk that he's demonstrating even
if
he is the only uk on the map at the time
he doesn't lose his engine he doesn't
lose his awareness
so this brings me to the the point i'm
wishing to make
aikido if you read about it or a sense
he said
aikido is designed for multiple attack
multiple means many not
one now if you look at facebook youtube
i don't care what masters you want to
choose
very rarely will you see them containing
zanjin
looking for those who are not there
but maybe
we're in a pandemic at the moment as i
make this film
and it seems to be spreading around the
world and not
declining it's very sad for all the
people that will lose their lives
who knows he might be one of us or
myself
in the future
but these films possibly will be here
when we're all gone because
they'll be out there on the net unless
somebody takes them off or he raises
them in some way
they'll be there for posterity
so what i'm saying i hope i don't regret
one day but i don't think so because to
me
is basics so basic aikido
means that you have to learn how to deal
with multiple attack
multiple attackers
so please
look at the videos where
whatever format you may see them on
see is the person whether they're the
teacher
or demonstration are they using their
zanshin
are they just busy demonstrating with
the one student
that they've got because of the pandemic
i fear
that the numbers in the clubs are
getting smaller
and as they get smaller it'll be even
harder
to stop going from just multiple attack
that
i don't see taut anywhere now
or it's maybe taught on very very rare
occasions
because we don't have the numbers he's
one it's going to reduce
so we won't have the numbers so does
that mean
the evolution of aikido will
reduce to one-on-one
if it does this then it's not her sense
is aikido
it's becoming you against another
how can you over open heart and say
please go past i don't wish to fight you
you how can you have that attitude
when there's only one person and you're
wanting to look good
this leads on to another problem
in the one-to-one demonstrations or
confrontations that we're seeing
on film very often
the teacher will do lots of wonderful
moves
and ending up on one knee if not both
knees
with multiple attack this isn't possible
because
you would have to deal with the other
people unless you want to be
beaten or kicked to death because you're
down below them
so it's leading into bad habits of
aikido
the only time since he said you should
be on your knees or one knee
is at the end of your demonstration
or at the end of your tether really
when you're exhausted and cannot
carry on anymore apart from that
the japanese used to train on their
knees to make their hip
movement better and build their power
it wasn't just to go down on the first
okay one to one so to show a technique
by going down on a one to one
means that you've lost the multiple
attack zan shin
you've lost the fight
from all the other attackers around you
thank you for listening i hope you
i hope if nothing else it's giving you
food for thought and whether you want to
disregard it
or not they're my views
and there'll be other views obviously
you will agree and disagree on in time
thank you for your time